(Alarm sounds)
James:
I never wanted this for you.
♪♪
I wanted a totally different
life.
James:
A steady paycheck,
kids,
James:
a family.
♪♪
Dad, tell me there's a way out
of this?
James:
Not a quick one.
♪♪
We would like you to transfer to
another prison and befriend
someone.
Lauren:
To elicit a confession.
♪♪
We suspect that this man killed
14 women.
But we only have one of the
bodies.
♪♪
Larry has vivid dreams.
Tell me about them.
In my dreams, I kill woman.
♪♪
Larry:
But they're just dreams.
♪♪
And this prison, where the
guy is?
Lauren:
Maximum security, specializing
in the criminally insane.
♪♪
You want me to check into hell?
James:
And befriend the demon?
Not for all the money in the
world.
How about freedom?
♪♪
Lauren:
Paul's conviction's on appeal.
He could win and walk.
Lauren:
You have the chance to stop him.
Don't approach him too early or
he'll  know we sent you for him.
♪♪
Larry:
Why are you looking at me like
that?
Like you know me.
♪♪
If it gets out that you're
here to snitch...
♪♪
J. Cater:
...that's going to be a very
unfortunate day.
♪♪
Lauren:
Accelerate your timetable.
If he walks, he'll kill.
♪♪
Lauren:
Again and again.
♪♪
Larry:
You think you could be in
danger,
you are in danger.
♪♪